hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
look at the question
when does aging really begin now short
answer
we don't really know but long answer
going into some detail about the two
examples
of rejuvenation and introducing the
concept of ground zero
the lowest biological age at which both
organism or life and aging begin
and then talking about lowering ground
zero is what you'll get
if you watch the rest of this video and
so a lot of what i'll be talking about
in this video has come from this recent
opinion piece that i read
the ground zero of organism or life and
aging that i found pretty interesting so
i thought i'd share it here
so i'll start with a question what do
you have in common
with a car well cars and other animal
objects
age over time like we do however for
cars
this aging is irreversible whilst
rejuvenation
is a process that can distinguish living
organisms
from inanimate objects and this enables
life
to continually renew itself with each
generation
now there are many different ways that
you could define rejuvenation
but one way is to define rejuvenation as
an ability to lower the biological age
now what defines biological age really
is a video of its own
but if we can agree that biological age
represents the percentage of aging
and throw chronological age out of the
window then i think it's fair to say
if you want to know when aging begins
you need to define at what point
biological age is the lowest and so in
this opinion piece
they define this lowest point as ground
zero
so when does ground zero actually occur
well
to understand this we need to talk about
what happens during early embryogenesis
the best place to start is conception
when the egg is fertilized by the sperm
and interestingly it was initially
thought that your gametes
the sperm and egg were immortal and this
idea dates back to the 19th century when
organ freisman proposed the separation
of ageless germline and
aging soma however considering the time
of conception
the human germline has been somewhat
metabolically active
for two or more decades and during that
time
must have accumulated some damage
whether it's through metabolic
byproducts
genetic mutations or modified proteins
so whilst gametes may appear
biologically younger than other tissues
they still show signs of aging therefore
for new life to begin in the same young
state as in the previous generation
the zygotes must somehow remove this
damage and decrease its biological age
to the level of the germline age in the
previous generation
therefore conception is not ground zero
so on our hypothetical graph if we start
at conception due to the presence of
some types of damage
the biological age will not be
effectively at ground zero
and so we'll place it around here for
now and so during the very early sages
post-conception the zygote undergoes a
variety of different changes
for example it's been reported that
telomeres are extended during this early
time period
in addition to the erasing of epigenetic
marks and genetic imprinting that's been
received from the different gametes
moreover the divisions of the early
zygotes may allow for clearing up
and dilution of molecular damage now
it's still unclear whether these
different processes
are linear or they happen gradually or
in different ways
or whether there's some kind of temporal
trajectory to it
or how much this process is even
regulated and so just as a brief aside
it would be very interesting to further
understand this rejuvenation process
as it could help us better understand
somatic cell rejuvenation which i'll
come onto a little bit later
now we know that this rejuvenation
process cannot go on forever
and at some point the trajectories are
going to be reversed
and therefore there will be an
inflection points and it's this
inflection point that could be
considered
ground zero and the authors of this
paper hypothesize
that this ground zero point corresponds
with mid embryogenesis
and the reason why it's a little bit
fake at the moment is partly because
studying early embryogenesis
is incredibly difficult and is obviously
a very sensitive time
moreover especially with human embryos
in the lab they can only be studied up
to 14 days post-conception
however one of the very interesting
points made in this article
is that this ground zero states during
mid-embryogenesis
may correspond with the so-called
phylotopic stage
and this is defined as the time point in
the development of an animal
when it most closely resembles other
species so
second question for this video take a
look at these images
which one of these early embryos do you
think will develop into a human
picks one well turns out the one that
will develop into a human is the one on
the far
right and so this phylotypic stage has
two implications
firstly it may mean that results found
by studying
different model organisms at early
embryogenesis could be transferable to
human embryogenesis
and this is particularly important given
the fact that human embryos don't reach
the phylotypic stage
until four weeks after fertilization the
second implication
is that this phylotypic stage may be
representing the ground zero state as it
suggests that this stage is
evolutionarily conserved and therefore
very important
now another really interesting point
made in this article is the fact that
they suggest the biological age at
ground zero must be
above zero that's to say the biological
age never effectively reaches
zero and there seem to be two key points
to support this
firstly during early embryogenesis when
the biological age appears to be
decreasing
there isn't any selective pressure to
decrease it any further
beyond doing what is required or
essential for further development
suggesting therefore that the damage
that isn't removed would only become
relevant much later
in life when the organism has already
passed its genes to its next generation
the second point is that some damage
cannot be removed the most obvious
example being
genetic mutations and on from that it
therefore suggests that there could be
some heritability of the biological age
at ground zero
therefore suggesting as well that
there's variants among different
individuals within a population
between sexes and across different
species and so given this information it
raises the question
can ground zero be lowered with the idea
that with a lower ground zero
there could be a reduced biological age
throughout life leading to an extended
lifespan
and health span and so this article kind
of talks about two main ideas to be able
to achieve this
the first one is the idea that to get to
a lower ground zero
you could extend this early rejuvenation
process
and one way that this could be done is
by bisecting early embryos
the idea that those cells then have to
go through further stages of development
before they reach this ground serious
date which could also be this phylotypic
stage
the second example they talk about is
the fact that at the moment these
rejuvenation states cannot
remove genetic mutations and this is
relevant given the fact that apparently
human genomes on average have six
ultra rare highly damaging mutations
each accounting for an average decrease
of six months of life
and so obviously there'll be a large
variation in that that could be
implicating lifespan
and so these mutations could effectively
be fixed by using different genome
editing technologies
now whilst it may be possible to do
these things it doesn't mean that they
should be done
and the only reason i really talked
about it here is due to the fact that
we've been talking about ground zero and
it just seemed like a natural extension
to this discussion
but actually the more interesting
reasons as i stated earlier in terms of
understanding early rejuvenation
processes
goes in line with trying to understand
rejuvenation of somatic
cells and so somatic cells refer to
cells that aren't your gamete cells
so basically any cell in your body that
isn't a sex cell
and so can somatic cells also be
rejuvenated
that means reducing the biological age
of a somatic cell
well yes the most go-to example now
being the rejuvenation of fibroblast
cells to so-called induced pluripotent
stem cells
by the expression of so-called yamanaka
factors
transcription factors that can reverse
the state
of the somatic cell type to a
pluripotent state
pluripotent referring to the fact that
this cell now has the potential to turn
into different types of cells
and this discovery by doctors junior
yamanaka back in 2006
pretty much launched a new era of
regenerative medicine
and this branch of medicine includes
methods to regrow repair or replace
damaged or diseased cells
and includes the generation of
therapeutic stem cells tissue
engineering and the production of
artificial organs
and another term you may come across
when reading about this field is
cellular reprogramming
because it's the idea that you can
reprogram a somatic cell
a cell that's been differentiated back
in two weeks pluripotent stem cell-like
states
and a lot of research is being conducted
into using
cellular reprogramming in different
therapies and i mentioned work from the
david sinclair lab last year
whereby they showed that they could use
cellular reprogramming to restore
fission
in aged mice and so in this manner the
aging process is effectively reversed
because the biological age of those
cells gets reduced and so the last main
point that i want to touch upon from
this article
is how we can kind of think of cellular
reprogramming
as a potentially more advanced version
of the current approaches to try and
delay the aging process and so the
author describes these interventions
such as psenolytics and metabolic
manipulation
as partial reprogramming stating that
although these approaches are extremely
important and
may somewhat decrease the biological age
they may only represent
fragmentary or partial rejuvenation
strategies
and a good way to try and understand
this is through an analogy whereby
aging is akin to gravity whereby it's a
fundamental force of nature that can
never truly be reversed
whereby gerry protective therapies could
slow down this flow
like the way that canals can slow down
rivers but can never reverse it
on the other hand rejuvenation
technologies could be thought of as
water pumps
and to use a different analogy this time
rocket science
if aging in biology is akin to gravity
in rocket science
then if rockets can fly and escape earth
scripts
without actually reversing gravity then
there's hope that by further
understanding
rejuvenation and early development and
beyond could help us to better
understand
the underlying biochemical mechanisms
that underpin rejuvenation
that will have great potential for
different therapeutic uses
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video a big shout out
to all my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening